我前一陣子去了迪拜你一下飛機就感覺到了另一個星球上一樣50多度的地表溫度先是茫茫的一片沙漠然後沙海裡就若隱若現的出現了一個現代城市的剪影你就來到了另一個世界一個奢華到讓你眼花繚亂的世界
下面就是世界上最高的摩天大樓。下面就是世界上最大的購物中心。警察開著頂級超跑、頂級豪車在那巡街。兩萬美元一晚的總算逃放。體驗一把什麼叫做睡覺睡到破產。你還可以去私人動物園裡遛老虎。在這麼個沙漠城市裡滑雪。迪拜甚至人工填海，造了兩個巨型的棕櫚島。注意哈，我說這個棕櫚島，不是說島上種點棕櫚樹那麼簡單。而是整個島的形狀，你從衛星上看，就像棕櫚樹。你瞅瞅，人家炫富都不是炫給你看的，是炫給外星人看的。
2024年，迪拜是全球富豪移居最多的目的地。你說，它是怎麼從一個偏遠的沙漠城市，變成了現在全球最強大、最光鮮亮麗的城市之一？可能很多朋友想當然就會覺得，這不送福爾提嗎？人家是中東土豪，那肯定是靠石油嘛。我跟你說，那你就草率了。其實迪拜的石油很少很少，現在只能佔到它GDP的1%。
而它的發展也伴隨了很多迪拜政府可能不希望你看到的陰暗面大量被壓榨的外來勞工被活活熱死也是黑幫毒販洗錢者的溫床咱們今天就來探究一下迪拜包括中東它非常獨特的經濟模式和發展思路它又面臨著怎樣的風險和挑戰
首先啊，迪拜它不是一個國家，它是阿聯酋裡邊的一個酋長國。阿聯酋的全稱叫阿拉伯聯合酋長國，是由七個酋長國聯合起來組成的。它經濟的主要單位都不是整個國家，而是裡邊每一個酋長國。他們有非常大的自主權，享有幾乎百分之百的財權。就我的地盤上，我的稅收，我的石油，完全歸我。立法也在很大程度上都可以自己定。中央政府可能就是統一一下貨幣，管管外交，國防，聯絡一下各個酋長國什麼的。
這些酋長國裡最主要的倆就是阿布扎比跟迪拜佔了整個阿聯酋GDP的80%這每個酋長國都有自己的酋長叫埃米爾所以一般阿聯酋它有一個不成文的規定阿聯酋的總統是由阿布扎比的酋長來當而阿聯酋的總理是由迪拜酋長來當這倆人可以說是阿聯酋權力最高的兩個人所以你也能看出來這個中央政府跟各個酋長國之間它其實不是一個那種上下級的關係更像是一個聯合政府的感覺看朋友們
就這回我不是去中東嗎你就能感覺幾乎所有的什麼酒店辦公樓都會掛著這兩個人照片我還特意打聽了一下這應該不是一個硬性規定就只是一個普遍的現象以示尊重所以你可見這兩位在阿聯酋的地位其實在19世紀的時候中東這一片還並沒有發現大量的石油可以說是非常原始
這些酋長國各自也都是獨立的就像是那種一個個小漁村那時候迪拜經濟主要的收入來源就倆一個是靠撈珍珠另一個是海盜因為迪拜它的地理位置非常關鍵它處於波斯灣通向外界世界的唯一通道其實就非常適合打劫
整的最後英國人實在是受不了了就跟這些酋長國之間簽了一個那種休戰條約大概意思就是說你們別搶我了這是煩死了我呢作為日不落帝國我可以保護你們並且給你們一些這個貿易上的合作所以在英國人的統治之下呢迪拜慢慢就變成了一個不小的貿易港口
但是從1930年開始﹐迪拜經歷了一段長達30年的經濟震盪。一是受到美國經濟大蕭條和二戰的影響﹐全球貿易萎靡﹐還跟邊上的阿布扎比摩擦不斷﹐更倒楣的你知道是什麼﹐出現了一個日本人﹐叫玉木本﹐就是米奇摩托﹐這哥們發明瞭人工養殖的珍珠﹐就讓生產天然珍珠的迪拜﹐直接躺牆。總之啊﹐二戰之後的迪拜﹐大概就是一個三萬人左右的﹐浮浮通通的小漁村﹐你怎麼看也不會覺得﹐它日後能有什麼崛起
就在這個時候，迪拜迎來了轉機，它發生了三件大事。一，就是1971年阿聯酋成立了。當時隨著英軍的撤軍，這些酋長國決定拉起手來合夥過日子，這樣迪拜至少不用跟旁邊的阿布扎比在每天明爭暗鬥打來打去了。迪拜遇到的第二個轉機，就是它發現了石油。
沒錯，迪拜也是有時有的，只是不多，據估算大概是40億桶。這是什麼概念呢？我簡單估算了一下，如果按照現在的油價再跑去一些開採成本，它大概值2000億美元，相當於迪拜不到兩年的GDP。
所以怎麼說呢這肯定是一大筆財富但也絕對談不上讓他一百年衣食無憂這種地步那就不像邊上的阿布扎比那真是挖到寶石油儲量有920一桶是迪拜的23倍全球有超過5%的石油儲量就在那麼大一點點小地方上所以說迪拜跟阿布扎比他倆雖然緊挨著也都屬於阿聯酋但他倆的騎石手牌是完全不一樣的你看這個就是迪拜歷史上的石油開採量91年之前大概每天還能保持在30萬桶之後就一路下滑
現在每天也就產5萬桶就不像邊上的土豪阿布扎比同學每天能產300萬桶不過話說回來也正是因為迪拜他發現了石油但又不多足夠讓他手上有第一桶進去支配但又不足以讓他失去奮鬥的動力逼著他早早就意識到了這個可持續發展的重要性所以說這41桶石油就是激發他潛力剛剛好的量也成為了他的第二大轉機哎 你看咱這不有點辯證的角度看問題了
迪拜的第三個轉機就是他趕上了一位非常有遠見的酋長叫Rashid 拉希德我順便吐個槽這些個酋長的名字長的實在是太像了因為他們的名字是要打的組組份份好多個人的名字都放在裡頭的所以你看他們名字感覺都差不多你得一個一個對不然就特別容易搞混但我指的這個非常有遠見的酋長就是指1958年到90年執政的這個酋長拉希德‧本‧薩伊德‧阿拉馬克頓也是奠定迪拜發展契機的一人酋長
其實你想阿聯酋不是酋長制嗎？理論上這塊土地上的稅收、石油都是歸酋長他們家的也就是歸這個馬克吐姆家族所有它其實是可以自由揮霍的但這個拉希德他心裡就非常清楚迪拜的處境他說過一句非常有名的話我祖祖輩輩都是騎駱駝我現在或許可以開奔馳我的兒子、孫子或許可以開路虎但再往後的子孫可能就又要騎回駱駝了這說明什麼？
說明他們非常喜歡路虎開玩笑說明他認識到了這個可持續發展的重要性我不能讓我的子孫再回去騎駱駝所以他一上來就不惜重金搬走基建對於當時迪拜那麼落後的一個地區基建可以說是一切的基礎他建造了電力線路電話服務還有迪拜的第一個機場等等而拉希德很快也意識到了一點迪拜除了有石油以外他還有一張非常關鍵的手牌是取之不盡用之不竭的是什麼呢就是它的地理位置
你看中東它位於亞歐非的中間而迪拜又在波斯灣的入口處所以誇張一點說它就是在整個亞歐大陸的一個中心所以很自然的拉希德就開始大型土木建港口先是1972年建了一個拉希德港一看還是不夠1979年又開始大動工程建成了著名的捷貝阿里港也是現在全球前十大的集裝箱港口之一
但我跟你說迪拜可不是搞一搞基建建個大港口它就完了你想全球大港口多了去了但迪拜可就這麼一個拉希德還是非常有遠見的他想把迪拜建成一個全球的商業中心不依賴石油也不光靠貿易你怎麼能成為商業中心呢對吧這裡頭重中之重就是投資你得有足夠的錢流進來來撬動全球的資本和人才來幫我發展這個在短期內可以說是最快最有效的所以你會看到一會兒咱們要說的各種策略各種政策它非常主要的一個目標就是吸引外資吸引人才你看它是怎麼做的
首先就是法律跟文化上我得跟世界接軌
你要知道阿拉伯文化它其實跟現代的商業文化差別還是挺大的你就比如說男女平等上在傳統的阿拉伯文化裡它是可以一夫多妻的而且女性又不能獨自出門包括很多大多數社會活動都會受到限制但拉希德心裡非常清楚敵敗想要吸引外資想要走向世界那就必須得先過了男女平等這關所以他從70年代開始就開放女性教育開放女性的工作權利等等比如你看邊上的沙特他是到2018年才允許女性開車
但迪拜這不的，一直都可以隨便開。大概意思就是說，歐洲人美國人，來看看，我們跟沙特可是不一樣的，我們這男女平等。
再比如說伊斯蘭教的文化裡它是不能飲酒的所以大部分的阿拉伯國家裡面其實對飲酒是完全禁止的但拉希德他也知道你要想成為商業中心你怎麼可能不讓人喝酒你覺得這可能嗎那聊嗨了誰還不喝兩杯呢所以他也說了你們外國人想在我這喝酒沒問題只要你不是穆斯林在指定的場所裡邊你愛怎麼喝怎麼喝這些都好商量
咱再舉個例子比如說根據伊斯蘭教的傳統他週五是要做大禮拜的所以大部分的阿拉伯國家他的週末是週五跟週六然後週日上班我跟你說這次我去沙特的時候我就挺納悶的你說大禮拜天的商場怎麼一個人也沒有呢後來一打聽才知道人家星星天是在上班但迪拜為了跟國際接軌從2022年開始週末也改成了週六跟週日
這就是一些例子哈總之呢雖然你現在去迪拜還是會感覺到有一些阿拉伯文化的限制但它已經是中東這個地區裡邊最開放最自由最西化的地區了
而且我跟你說我跟他們聊天的時候我發現他們那人對文化開放的用詞可以說是非常的巧妙他們不管這種叫自由化或者開放化這種特別正面的詞就好像顯得原來的傳統文化非常的封閉非常保守一樣他們管這種開放叫做世俗化就非常的中性大概就是說我們傳統文化也沒有什麼不好的我就是為了發展來迎合你們這些世俗除了世俗化迪拜的第二大招就叫自由化
比如剛才咱說到的捷貝阿里港，它為什麼能成為中東第一大港口？當然地理位置、基建這是一方面，但更重要的是因為它身處在一個自由區，叫做捷貝阿里自由區。一個只有57平方公里的區域，卻吸引了整個阿聯酋36%的外國直接投資，貢獻了迪拜五分之一的GDP。
在這個自由區裡外國的投資人是可以享有百分之百的所有權不需要牽扯任何的本地合作夥伴同時在稅收上15年內他不收任何的公司稅跟收入稅就這麼簡單零你看光這兩條就對海外大量的企業和創業者非常吸引力它就像是在阿聯酋國家裡邊扣出來了一塊完全沒有國籍概念沒有限制的飛地飄在空中完全自由除此之外還有非常完善的配套設施倉庫配套服務等等的這一系列制度吸引了將近1萬個企業在這裡註冊
而你以為它就是個特例嗎？NO NO NO NO NO類似的自由區迪拜先後建了26個比如說它的網絡城媒體城國際金融中心珠寶城等等都是零收入稅加上這個行業的配套措施而且我跟你說其實不只是在這些自由區整個迪拜都沒有個人所得稅迪拜就是想用這種壓倒性的福利力度來吸引大家來中東這個乍聽你可能覺得鳥不拉屎的地方投資建立分公司甚至總部其實也帶動起來它的金融行業
那你看哈，這麼優惠開放的稅收政策，不光吸引公司，人也會跟著一起來。你只要在迪拜投資200萬迪拉姆，大概就是50萬美元，不到400萬人民幣，就可以拿下他10年的工作簽證，號稱叫做黃金簽證。所以大量的富豪都會選擇在迪拜投資房地產，甚至直接移居到迪拜。你比如說印度首富安巴尼和貝克漢姆，都在剛剛我們說的棕櫚島買了房。
有一家公司叫做H&P它會估算百萬富翁也就是淨流動資產在100萬美元以上的這些富豪每年在各個國家之間流動的情況它就估計在2024年會有6700名富人淨流入到阿聯酋全球排名第一遠遠甩開了第二名的美國和第三名的新加坡而這裡頭的絕大多數其實都流向了迪拜
不過迪拜這麼寬鬆自由的資本吸引政策就引發了一個非常嚴重的問題它從資本的角度來講真的可以說是藏汙納垢成了一個全球的洗錢中心全球資本監管的這麼一個盲區迪拜雖然明面上也是有一些反洗錢的法律法規可實際上我跟你說就只要你錢進來
這個錢是真錢那我就收而且我保你安全就在迪拜這麼多年從來沒發生過因為洗錢或者因為錢不乾淨就遭遇沒收這種重大的案件我就給你舉一個最最常見同時又極其簡單粗暴的洗錢方式很多人呢他會從英國的西斯羅機場帶巨量的現金就塞在行李箱裡頭帶到迪拜境內因為西斯羅機場他不會查你離境帶的現金迪拜呢又不會查你入境帶的現金所以你就拿這個行李箱的現金大搖大擺就這麼進來了
然後你可以把它存進銀行，或者直接買房。正常，大部分經濟體，你拿這麼巨量的現金，人家肯定會覺得你行為可疑，肯定會被盤查詢問，你這錢是怎麼來的呀，乾不乾淨呀，你給我提供證明等等。但是在迪拜，你放心，我絕對一個字都不說，一個問題都不多問，只要你這個錢是真的，就可以。你要是想再穩妥一點，你甚至可以建一個空殼公司，用這個公司的名義在迪拜買房。
這個售樓處也不會問你這個公司背後的任何信息。你再比如說，前兩年美國不是制裁俄羅斯富豪嗎？這些俄羅斯富豪上億的資產，在歐美又待不下去，他又不想轉移回俄羅斯，怎麼辦呢？去迪拜。
前兩天某全球知名通信軟件的創始人布羅夫在法國巴黎被捕他原來是俄羅斯人你知道他現在是什麼國籍嗎就是阿聯酋當然他很多種國籍了阿聯酋只是其中一個你再比如說很多幣圈的大佬最近都喜歡把總舖放到迪拜而且會在當地買房你說為什麼呀我們知道幣圈還是挺亂的或者說是非常自由那就有很多灰色玩法或者灰色收入你要是在東亞或者歐美這些地方不光稅收高加密貨幣還可能會面臨非常大的政策風險但迪拜就明說了說你來我們這
我們歡迎你們我們支持加密貨幣一直以來對於這種灰色交易迪拜政府都可以說是睜一隻眼閉一隻眼畢竟它也是從中受益的但最近幾年迫於全球的壓力而且迪拜它確實自己名聲有點被搞臭大家一聽說你的總部設在迪拜你的房子在迪拜
他下意識就會覺得你這個錢可能是有點問題的有點那個劣幣驅逐良幣的意思所以迪拜政府最近也開始採取更嚴格的反洗錢措施總之迪拜確實靠著非常自由的寬鬆的稅收政策和貿易政策吸引了大量資本但這樣也沒完你說他就是為了自由化那他幹嘛費那麼大勁去建咱最開始提到那麼誇張的建築呢就純粹為了炫富嗎那顯然不是這就是迪拜的另一大殺手鐧營銷
你可別聽著營銷就感覺是個貶義詞什麼虛假營銷過度營銷這是不好但單純營銷它其實就是個中性詞我就宣傳我自己嘛讓大家知道我迪拜就非常會搞這套
你看哈大家一提到威尼斯就會想到水城一提到巴黎就會覺得浪漫那我怎麼能一提到迪拜人們先想到的不是石油不是沙漠我不是中東中東城市裡的一個小同名而是前衛現代化有記憶點的呢迪拜他就覺得說我不能是說普普通通質量好或者優秀就OK我就得做到哪怕一張照片就讓人有非常深刻的印象
這也是為什麼迪拜幹點什麼就得追求世界之最追求與眾不同即使它會耗費巨大的成本你比如說迪拜之框就是建得跟個畫框似的大樓咱們都學過三角形是最穩定的四邊形是非常不穩定的所以這個大樓不管是從建造的成本難度利用空間投資回報率每個角度考慮它都不合理但是
它越不合理它就越吸引眼球啊你再比如說咱們最開始說那兩個著名的棕櫚島它為什麼費那麼大錢人工填海造出來那麼個奇形怪狀的島這些項目每個都是上百億美元的投資你單從整個項目的投資回報來看肯定是不划算的或者說收益跟風險不成正比但這些項目對整個城市的形象來說是有非常大的提升作用的就有很大的正外部性
你不能單看這一個項目的回報率你就好比說巴黎建了一個IFR鐵塔你要單從這一塊土地的投資回報來講那肯定不make sense對吧你一年門票能收多少錢我還真查了一下他一年門票收還不到一億歐都不夠他維護的成本但他對整個巴黎有多重要是吧我相信大家心裡應該都清楚這個其實就是迪拜的思路
我不能保證建一個建築就能像埃菲爾鐵塔那麼炸但我可以以量取勝我就給你建幾十個奇形怪狀的埃菲爾鐵塔來增加我的記憶點有了這些記憶點迪拜再去滿世界的放自己宣傳片找名人代言就可以說是事半功倍產生更大的話題度
你看那個哈利法塔，它裡面能容納超過3萬人起居，高吧？壯觀吧？可就是因為它的人口密度太高了，配套的排汙系統，在最開始還沒到位的情況下，它就開始營業了。所以最早的十多年，它每天都要靠卡車，一車一車的把這幾萬人的排洩物給拉走。所以你看，這其實從側面反映出來了迪拜它建城市的一個思路，就是後端亂一點，可以，但前端我一定得風險亮麗，我得炸！
但另一方面這些神奇建築背後的代價也是巨大的要知道在迪拜有超過88%都是外來打工人他們主要就是來自南亞像印度、巴基斯坦、孟加拉等等為了更高的收入來到迪拜但這裡有很多其實都遭受到了非常嚴重的人權侵犯
比如說有些人來迪拜打工，第一天他的護照就會被僱主給收走。那你要是想走想不幹了，都不行。就單這一點，其實就給僱主非常大的話語權，來壓榨員工了。再比如什麼拖欠工資，非常惡劣的居住環境，歧視，醫療保障不足等等，可以說是家常便飯。很多人每天被要求工作超過12個小時，而且沒有固定的休息日。你別忘了，他們可是經常要在50度的高溫環境下搬磚。據估算每年有上千名的外來勞工，叫自然死亡。
根據印度的大使館估算每年大概有100名的印度勞工會在阿聯酋自殺注意我只是說這種現象非常的普遍並不是所有打工人都這樣那不至於這些外來勞工的人權問題其實不光是比拜的問題整個中東都有類似的現象比如前兩年卡塔爾趕工世界盃的時候也涉及到了大量類似問題被曝光直到2017年迫於國際的壓力阿聯酋才通過了一個法案就要求工人每週要有一天的休息日但這項條款可以說到現在也沒有被完全貫徹
而且即使受到了人權侵犯他們都沒有渠道去維權因為在迪拜不管是警察還是法院幾乎永遠站在本地人這邊所以你看來自南亞的這些廉價勞動力可以說是迪拜奇蹟的一個黑暗之處
那反過來，迪拜本地人他們福利就非常多了。很大一部分人可以免費的分到土地，或者政府直接就送你房子。他們的教育、醫療、養老幾乎政府全包。男性結婚，政府就立刻送你19000美元的補助等等吧。就業上他們也有特權。阿聯酋政府他就要求，大部分的私企都要有一定比例的本地人，一般是4%到8%。所以每個公司都有幾個那種穆斯林的白袍員工，就跟他供著，跟個吉祥物似的。同樣的工作，他們的福利、工資也都會更好。
迪拜本地人的工資平均在五千到一萬五美元一個月而我們剛剛說的這些外來的打工人尤其是藍領的勞工他們的工資可以說只有本地人的十分之一最低可能也就兩百美元一個月好 咱說回到迪拜的發展雖然它有這樣那樣的問題但它的營銷確實是非常成功在它持續不斷不惜重金的投入下迪拜把現代化 前衛 奢華這些標籤可以說是牢牢的印到了人們的腦子裡也帶動了迪拜的一大支柱行業就是旅遊業
現在迪拜是全球第三大旅遊城市每年有超過1600萬人次的國際遊客我跟你說有一個公司我必須得拿出來單獨說一說它對迪拜的商業化旅遊業可以說是太重要了你知道是哪個公司嗎就是阿聯酋航空
別看他名字叫阿聯酋航空，感覺像是阿聯酋這個國家的。他其實是迪拜政府的，也可以說是馬克圖姆他們家的。他的CEO就是馬克圖姆他們家一個非常重要的人來擔當。這一家公司的營收，就相當於迪拜超過四分之一的GDP。而且他對迪拜的作用，不僅僅是GDP的貢獻，還有就是營銷。你是不是一提到阿聯酋航空，就會想到奢華。他每年要承接5000萬人次的乘客，那可就是5000萬人次的廣告。
就算你只是去轉個機，我也得讓你見識見識迪拜有多豪。之後大家就會口口相傳，所以這也會導致很多人即使沒做過阿聯酋航空，但都聽說過它奢華。為了打造這個奢華的形象，阿航可以說是不計血本。你比如說全球最大的客機，就是那個雙層的空客A380,可以說是航空界的勞斯萊斯了。目前空客總共就交付了250億架，其中有123架，也就是說全球幾乎一半的A380,都是被阿聯酋航空給match的。
你看啊，咱剛才講迪拜政府的各種策略，它又使勁花錢，又減稅，還沒怎麼有石油，那你是不是就有疑問了，它的錢是哪來的呢？好問題喲！
確實，稅收收入只佔到了迪拜政府收入的三分之一。他可能也會從增值稅、關稅這些地方扣一扣，但這不是他收入的大頭。大頭在哪呢？我跟你說，毫不誇張地說，大半個迪拜就是他政府自己家的。那些各種大大小小的項目，也都是他所謂這些國企開發的。這些國企賣房的收入，酒店的營收，還有大大小小各種亂七八糟的收費，最終很大一部分，
其實都流向了迪拜政府我跟你說個很有意思的數據在迪拜有80%到90%的本地人口也就是絕大多數的本地人都是因為政府部門國企工作的所以你看迪拜這個城市是不是有點像一個巨大的房地產開發商首先幾乎所有的本地人都是給政府工作都是他的員工董事長就是這個酋長然後這個公司他招來了7倍於本地人數量的外地人就像是個外包團隊幫他們搞基建搞城市建設等這項目都完工了以後
每年又會吸引來40倍於本地人的外商、遊客來消費、投資。政府這家公司就有點像個地主在這收錢。是吧，你有沒有感覺把它想像成一個公司好像更容易理解一點？基於它這個公司型政府的特點，咱就站在經濟的角度來淺分析一下。
你看一般的政府它有點相當於一個經濟的旁觀者管理者而像迪拜這種幾乎完全國有化的公司型政府它就完全是這個經濟的參與者那些龐大的地產開發項目它就是政府自己加的即使像迪拜這麼有錢它也得是要舉債去建的所以經濟好的時候它會更賺錢但萬一經濟出現問題的時候它其實更容易破產所以說迪拜這個城市這個酋長國從長期來講它非常底層的一個特點就是它有更高的風險
這個是迪拜政府五年期債務的信用利差簡單來說這個利差越高就說明它的違約風險越高你看這幾年迪拜的信用狀況確實不錯利差才70多個基點但08年金融危機那會都飆到900多了當時迪拜政府它也確實非常激進像那些棕櫚島、迪拜世界這些人工島項目其實都是在那個時候建的08年之前那會迪拜世界集團的債務一度高達800億美元結果全球金融危機爆發它立刻就陷入了現金流危機
而你知道他是怎麼渡過難關的嗎還是得虧了他邊上的石油土豪大哥阿布扎比來幫他兜底借了他100億美元還給他擔保才幫助這個亮亮腔腔的迪拜完成了債務重組其實不光這一次包括13年和18年這個阿布扎比都兩次幫助迪拜完成了債務重組
你看這個是過去20來年迪拜的房地產價格指數這兩年價格確實挺猛的但是你很明顯能看到這個波動其實是非常劇烈的而這個波動呢它其實會直接反映到政府的收入政府的信用所以長期來看相對於一般的國家政府來說迪拜它其實是有更高的風險尤其是它又不像其他中東那些地區有石油保地當然風險更高它預期的收益也更大所以說這個風險高呢不能說是它的問題只能說是它的特點咱就是這麼嚴謹
現在的迪拜它又面臨這一系列非常大的挑戰有一些我們常聽說的非常直觀的比如說沙漠化嚴重缺水嚴重它的人造島正在下沉包括我們剛才說的洗錢問題再來勞工的人權問題等等這些也都是不小的挑戰但是它在短期內也不是很棘手我認為對迪拜來說它現在面臨最大的挑戰其實是競爭就來自中東其他城市其他國家的競爭
隨著新能源飛速發展全球的去石油化可能比大家想像會來得更快中東這些石油土豪們可能慢慢也意識到了我這石油可能都還沒用光呢人們就已經不需要它了而且很可能就是在十年之內這些國家也面臨著和幾十年前迪拜類似的處境就手裡有錢但是不可持續所以他們也都效仿著迪拜的模式可以說是傾全國之力砸重金打造自己的未來之城趁自己還有點家底趕緊轉型
迪拜不是減免稅收搞自貿區嗎？我也搞。你看它周圍那一圈，卡塔爾，沙特，巴林，阿曼，特威特也都照糊了話條，減免稅搞自貿區。迪拜不是大搞建設，建那些吸引眼球的建築來宣傳自己嗎？我也建。你看沙特，卡塔爾，特威特都提出了自己的願景計劃，都在修建比迪拜更誇張，更不可思議的項目。
卡塔爾已經給世界盃建了大量的場館、酒店還正在建那個盧塞爾城直接給你來一個38平方公里20萬人口的新城各種智能化綠色能源都是從底層開始搭建阿布扎比正在建一個薩迪亞特島盧浮宮是已經建好了確實非常漂亮還在建各種博物館、度假村
最豪的沙特那就更敢想了你比如說他要建那個The Line就在沙漠裡直接起一個500米高寬200米全程170公里的線性城市全是兩排平行的摩天大樓人就在這裡頭起居生活然後外邊就全沙漠還有Oxygen一個八邊形懸浮結構的工業城市Trojana一個山地度假村還可以滑雪
當然迪拜也不甘示弱他正在籌辦宏大的2040未來城力爭要把迪拜變一個沙漠裡變成全球最宜居的城市他要搞一個環城的步行街全密閉24小時空調他要建更高的摩天大樓更大的商業中心更大的機場等等
我跟你說你現在要是去這些中東地區一個非常深刻的體會真的到處都在施工到處都在建各種新項目而這些所有的項目你甭管它多麼的新奇多麼的龐大都有一個共同的主題就是可持續發展它都會強調自己是零汙染零碳盤放其實就是想改變在人們心目中那個濕油土豪的標籤想要變成另一個迪拜甚至是更好的迪拜這也是為什麼你會感覺到中東這兩年各個地區都在非常活躍的舉辦各種賽事
你說卡塔爾為什麼要砸上千億辦世界盃在沙漠裡頭建一堆空調房足球場學弟歪嗎沙特足球隊為什麼要花重金去買C羅內馬爾本澤馬坦特等等的國際巨星他為什麼要去舉辦電競世界盃學弟歪嗎阿布扎比為什麼要請劉亦菲合作拍宣傳片那就更不用說了學弟歪嗎
你看迪拜確實已經建立起來了巨大的先發優勢但你不得不說他這些鄰居是真有錢預算都在千億美元以上沙特甚至超過了萬億美元就這燒錢的能力迪拜真是比不過現在的中東對資金對基建的需求是非常饑渴的以前那些無腦流向迪拜的錢現在可能都得心思心思對吧我是投迪拜呢還是投沙特還是投卡塔爾呢
哪一個的投資回報率更高這些都會給迪拜帶來非常大的競爭迪拜做任何事情它的成本都會提高這個其實是我覺得短期內對它最大的挑戰
最後我再跟大家稍微解釋一下這期視頻我用的數據其實並不多確實是因為迪拜它本身的數據比較有限大部分的數據都是整個阿聯酋的但在阿聯酋裡邊迪拜跟阿布扎比的情況又完全不一樣所以可能就也沒法用大家也就沒看到那些常規的通貨膨脹利率這些分析不過我估計我要是不說你們可能也沒發現